I've told Dev your father's dead it's
your fault Jessie but he's not dead he
only left a tea bags yeah 10 years ago
they do move stff around in that shop a
lot though I told Dev that he died on
the way to Jose's audition for dance
school okay great so I killed him sorry
it felt
right that's the plot have saved the
Last Dance I know I'm sorry it was on
Sky last night after you went to bed
luckily Dev wasn't watching cuz he was
on his iPad he's not dead he's not Billy
I'm sorry for saying that your father's
dead but trust me when you're you'll
understand can I talk to you about
something why are you
pregnant no okay good I dread the day we
have that conversation I never see any
condoms in your bin and Lord knows we
all hear you having sex remember
pregnancy is game over getting pregnant
with Josie was the worst mistake of my
life and not just because it was with
Josie should I go sorry I didn't realize
you were still here apparently I tried
to kick her away like giraffes at the
zoo and they can tell there's something
wrong with their baby but the nurses
just handed her back and told me she was
fine how wrong they were having Josie
meant that I was stuck with your father
for 18
years really imagine being stuck with
the same man trapped unable to leave for
18 years lock
down
wow that sounds
terrible